hey today we're doing an unboxing in my
kitchen mostly because I already had the
setup setup and this is actually too big
to keep it unbox on my upstairs and
boxing table so this is really the only
place that I could do it so prepare
yourself should I prepare myself because
we're unboxing like yourself surface to
do this thing is incredibly heavy how I
didn't even do this so there's three
different versions of the surface to do
and this is the mid-level range that I
have it's the one terabyte hard drive it
has the Intel Core i7 and a 16 gigs of
ram where is the lowest version as a 1
terabyte drive it's the Core i5 and has
a king's a ram whereas the highest level
has a 2 terabyte hard drive Intel Core
i7 as well but with 32 gigs of RAM
I have wonder if these things are
upgradable doesn't seem like it also
excited about this where are you
it's Microsoft Surface tile as you guys
know one of the huge draws of the
Microsoft Surface is for illustrators
designers and creative people because
this is something that you can attach
directly onto the screen it will allow
you to do all kinds of different
functionality inside of different
applications especially for illustrators
you're able to just turn the dial get
all kinds of different color palettes
and it helps you with your creativity
your artistic ability it'll make you
beep awesome that me make is that's shut
up over the boss you can't see me but
I'm doing some cutting back here put the
whole Wow whoa whoa whoa my god is this
awesome
like it just shows you lift it up but
that's not easy
it's heavy just heavy all right what do
we have here
[Music]
okay I'm I'll save it you might be
important I'll save it
oh what's in here sounds like a mouse I
was entirely 100% wrong it's the power
gable definitely the keyboard probably
the mouse as well stylus where's my
stylus here it is I like if this was a
full-length keyboard with a number-pad
now that we've got all of our stuff out
hope there's nothing else in here oh wow
look at this thing it's huge
look at that reflection doh
that's gonna be hard to avoid but this
thing's real thin this is a beautiful
beautiful whoa oh my god it's super
impressive I can imagine this getting
super smudgy if you're like drawing on
it all day especially with my smudge
body who are you they're really on there
aren't you sir
[Music]
I've turned it on for the first time
there's so much reflection I just wanted
to show you the Buddhist screen the
first time my battery's okay
touch screen I can touch it I don't need
a mouse English hello it's a say goodbye
to remembering and entering complex
passwords Windows hello is a more
personal way to sign into your device
just unplug it centered in the frame
okay
I guess how was it I just showed it my
face and say hi Cortana hello okay it's
officially set up now let's open up the
surface dial get this thing paired and
ready to go where's my knife god I'm
gonna hurt myself
oh there's whoa this that's it hold the
okay cool
oh geez oh my goodness this has a little
sticky feel on it so I'm left-handed and
I believe there's a setting in here that
you can switch depending upon what side
you would want to put it because if
you're left-handed
where's my style of yours least Euler's
I lose the Styles already
how'd you go everything is like already
paired and synced up this is how I used
to use a mouse that reflective surfaces
I would just put it like on my stomach
so what I wanted to really show you it's
gonna be kind of difficult because
there's so much reflection you zoom out
a little more does that help at all
let's get into a drawing program what we
have making sure it's you make sure
you're centered it's me I promise
[Music]
yes surface style ready to pair let's do
it
it's lighten up think you just missed it
connecting put you on oh gosh look I'm
not even it's this is what okay we're
gonna be doing some great work today
guys so now that the dial is connected
I'm inside of my program what I can do
is use this to choose different colors
like a green and then I'm gonna color
I'll pick my what mold I'll do a paints
like this and I just that's not the
right color
that's not the right color
there's also an undo here's a nice red
gosh I'm an artist here's some chalk I
can also do this which is pretty cool I
can just turn this and it'll change the
color Oh oops
it'll change the color as I turn the
dial okay can you see that can you see
my art he would call I could write with
my finger look at this good oh wow
Wow look it's like a real paper
while my service is officially set up so
I'm gonna take this on up to my office
and I'm gonna get it all set up and I'll
show you guys the final outcome all
right looking for me can you see me yes
look that cable management so I got it
all set up and honestly every time I try
to organize my cables they get destroyed
so at this point you know what I'm just
gonna leave it at this it's a hot mess
right now I'm gonna play some Diablo and
see how that works out okay here it is
let's return to my game so this was my
barbarian in a previous game that I
played I really even played this is so
long so it's been pretty fun actually to
play this but I'm gonna be traveling
soon so I'm thinking about just
downloading this on my Mac so I can play
when I'm traveling but this looks really
good the skeleton king was just
something about my character doesn't
leave her the disguise I couldn't think
of anything else creative and I was just
listening to the new remix by Justin
Bieber so that's it that's all I've got
for this video it is super late it is
10:09 let's past my bedtime I'll see you
guys later let me know what you guys
think in the surface studio and let me
know what you guys think Oh No
[Music]